when opening Theory again used some of
his preparation he's going to be armed
to the teeth at this point having just
played the World Cup the world uh rapid
team championship and okay he opens with
the English C4 so maybe a less
theoretical battle ahead I was going to
say do what you did in the first game
Fabiano where you have kind of got that
seven eight minute time advantage and
then try and put the pressure on with
white but
um okay Magnus replying with a really
flexible first move and in the end they
were like okay just come just come to
our library and then you can have open
access to it but you're right those
years were super formative for him when
his family moved there Simon but to your
point one of the big things about
Ireland has been his longevity and his
ability to adapt to this changing time
it's not something that a lot of players
from his generation have been able to do
he's been in the world top 10 for so
many years with the magnus's generation
being at the peak as well and I think
that's been really special about his
career Magnus has played the North Sea
hasn't he and is this a version of North
Sea David
and I'm going to take you all the way
back to the start position because
Magnus is famous for playing this
opening looks like he's going for the
modern defense but instead of feeling
tattooing this bishop he brings his
Knight out and this has a really bad
reputation or at least a dodgy
reputation Magnus has had mixed results
here including losing to Michael Adams
at the 2010 Olympiad but the whole idea
is to bring the Black Knight to the edge
it looks like an Alicorn defense you've
kind of provoked white into gaining
space in the center though uh but at the
cost of time and Magnus has got an
improved version of this uh where here
white for example could start attacking
the Knight already instead after C4 he
did the same thing he provoked the white
Pawn to step forward gaining space but
White's pieces are not backing up the
pawns here and look at what happened
Fabiano instead of going for the main
move as I believe Pawn takes Pawn when
the position becomes more rational he
pushed forward the four-point attack or
at least a spin on that and now after
this move he was forced to trade Queens
off the board and suddenly if we catch
up with the game this is the current
position
I think it's a disaster and that's um
especially not with white is that harsh
maybe just true yeah I mean the thing is
though there'll be people at home saying
but you know take a look at that pawn
chain that's very nice uh yeah tilt
adding to that as well adding to the
Magnus effect and so they won't
necessarily choose the most aggressive
openings if he plays provocatively they
won't necessarily choose everything
that's Cutting Edge because after all
they're happy with the draw Magnus has
castled to the left and uh poor fabby's
King it's violent at this point Knight
to D4 has landed and that forces uh the
White Knight to deal with the threat of
jumping in with a nasty night Fork
Knight to A3 yeah Simon I think your
move fits uh about time there we go
Magnus does player F6 hasn't hasn't gone
well Magnus has played very
provocatively and uh it is Magnus who
has the opening advantage and that we
did see the reason why white can't
capture the pawn on F6 and Fabby well
he's trying to exchange off pieces but
this is going to come at the cost of a
pawn but if for example I were to take
this Knight then a position such as this
would be hopeless uh black with two well
with a rook and three pawns for two men
abuses I mean it's still terrible but uh
oh Rook F1 where you have to make a move
like Rook F1 on the board you know that
things have gone wrong already it really
feels like there should be something
more in the position than capturing the
E5 Pawn he retains the Knight on the
board on D4 uh White Skin's still in the
center you can't uh pick up the pawn on
E5 because of the tactic that David
mentioned and the Knight comes in with
the check on F3 yeah at the very least
you trade off a set of Pawns I guess and
I think we're headed in this direction
Ivanka nice prediction game on point
there this has indeed happened this is
the game position and Magnus has a very
pleasant decision uh he can push forward
uh cementing the knights on a nice
outpost on S3 with a check next move or
you can just trade off after Rook to D1
and simplify the position better minor
piece as well this Knight better than
white snipe and Europa pawn and with a
safer King
everything adds up here he plays Rook to
f8 instead just keeping the tension
and lots of pieces are hanging yeah
suddenly white does have some threats at
least some hope of counter play Black's
night in the center that glorious
beautiful night is under Fire uh Magnus
still one Pawn up gotta find a way to
get out of this I mean a two-point
deficit would be absolute disaster you
don't come back from a two-point deficit
against uh Magnus fabi's already lost
the first game and as you pointed out
the bishop jumps in attacking The Rook
defending the Knight Magnus going
aggressive with the Rook he's still got
that extra Pawn
soon
that's not gonna be easy I'm expecting
him to try and activate the white King
right now there we go putting the
pressure on the black Bishop but this
does allow Magnus to trade off the
Bishops and then we get a knight and
pawn ending and you know what they say
about not important endings they're
basically the same as a poor King and
pawn endings every single factor that is
a huge consideration there it's the same
night in games there we go call Ivanka
and uh up on the clock as well Magnus
with an extra pawn and that 17th piece
that we keep talking about and that will
give him some hope here is it time for
some predictions do we think Fabiano is
going to hold this game it would be a
miracle if he does
can't see him holding this I mean
against Magnus I mean it's uh you know
it's it's possible but I'm very unlikely
keeps coming back to that whole point
right that it's against Magnus Magnus as
in-game player in the world yesterday I
remember him winning a game against Amin
in a 1919 game very instructive and uh
he knows what to do he knows it's all
about mobilizing the pieces we played
guess the ELO earlier if you had to
predict accuracy the accuracy that
Magnus has had in this game I'd love to
see what it is because it almost feels
like a Flawless game by black what do
you think it would be if the black king
is forced back to defend this uh support
on C7 that the White Knight is attacking
then at least white would gain some time
to go active himself and Magnus is going
for a race uh we do know that H pawns
and a pawns those Corner pawns The Rook
pawns there they are what night struggle
against the most and Magnus he's trying
to create a past Pawn for himself there
uh forced the white king passive now and
he's getting active with his own Knight
really instructive we talked about it
earlier today not materialistic at all
Magnus has given away all of his kind of
uh material advantage here level pawns
but suddenly the black king is super
career to the white king the Black
Knight superior to the White Knight and
some serious threats by Magnus Carlson
he so quickly went into this line of a
four-piece activity just giving up that
seat Bond and Ivanka you were on point
we're getting an update the accuracy
94.8 by Magnus Carlson in this one oh
disappointing you should never doubt my
guesses
this is incredible stuff so David he
does give up the C7 Pawn but he captures
the A2 Pawn so once again uh up material
but he might be losing another Pawn so
Magnus his track record is good and look
at this he doesn't even care about the
black e-pawn it's he's got bigger fish
to fry here A5 he's getting ready to run
with that one white B3 Pawn is the next
a target for the Black Knight do you
think he knows how the horsey moves
he's called good idea yeah
hahaha
yeah no it feels like a Magnus has uh
the queen and games knowing what the
queen belongs so difficult to find
checkmates even Magnus
will will lose the game if you check my
him it's a tough Journey up there but
yeah if you manage it it could be done
but right now it is magnus's King that
has marched on the board so Fabi didn't
go for that pawn on E7 he needs the
Knight to keep things guarded but Knight
C1 is coming in you still lose the B3
Bond still Fabius defending Knight D2
but as again it's a question of timing
you see that the Knight on D2 is
completely tied down and why it's pawns
they don't move they don't they can't do
anything and all family can do is just
Shuffle the king from the G2 Square to
the F2 square and now it's going to be
operation
porn time it's going to be operation
e-pawn time yeah look there you go
H5
maybe B6 if you want interesting you
know enjoy yourself yeah he's oh he's
six he's got E5 E4 because you want to
give up that e-pawn and grab the beep on
E6 is the movement the sadistic way
doing it so just take your time and
moving in one square at a time it's just
crazy no matter what position you give
him what middle game end game always his
opponents seem to barely be able to move
uh Magnus he just completely paralyzes
them and whites Knight tied down
defending the B Pawn the king tied down
and eventually one of them is deflected
at the cost of Black's E Pawn but now it
is one of those Corner pawns at the H
Pawn and Harry gonna become Queen
Harriet soon Simon yeah and you can even
go Knight takes B3 probably and get use
the other one I love the way he called
it trousers legs the other day I thought
that was cool so is he gonna go Knight
takes B3 yeah I think he will reborn
pick it up oh he is it's not even
sacrificing and uh yeah the trousers
legs are coming down right I mean for
her assignment yeah I mean it was a good
move and um on the board the problem
with is that you can only defend against
these pawns from one side and you can't
jump off the board
yeah it's game over Fabiano caruana
resigns and with that Magnus with a 2-0
lead he did make this one look easy